we worked as hard as we could to protect
people
in who live in care homes and of course
those who live in care homes
are some of the most vulnerable to this
disease because by its nature
it attacks and has more of an impact
on older people now when it comes to the
testing of people as they left hospital
and went into care homes we committed
to building the testing capacity to
allow that to happen
of course it then takes time to build
testing capacity
in fact one of the critical things we
did was set the 100
000 target back then to make sure we
built that testing capacity and it was
very effective
in doing so and then we were able to
introduce the policy of testing
everybody before going to
care homes but we could only do that
once we had the testing capacity
which i had to build because we didn't
have it in this country from the start
you know we started with a capacity of
less than two thousand in march
last year and and got to a hundred
thousand tests a day
um and um we set all of this out at the
time
in uh in public documents it's all a
matter of a public record
and i mean we work closely together on
it uh jenny
um i think i might just add to that from
a professional perspective i think uh
the testing is clearly important and as
secretary of state
has noted uh we have built a lot of
capacity this
this is all uh readily available now we
we do around a million tests a day
but i think actually one of the things
that sometimes gets forgotten in some of
the
conversations about testing is the
really important thing is not
testing says you have a problem the
intervention is very much about
isolation so when an individual leaves
whether it be
a hospital setting the guidance is very
much about
ensuring that there is appropriate
infection prevention control
both in the care home setting but
actually in separating that individual
from others because the test only gives
you the result
on the day the really important thing is
to be able to be sure that a patient
doesn't become
symptomatic and be able to transmit
infection for the subsequent incubation
period
so from an interventional perspective
that is critical
testing is really helpful um and i think
the the only other thing i would say is
it's um
you know the elderly uh who and the
vulnerable in residential settings have
been
a focus actually of a care subgroup uh
in the sage
[Music]
modeling group and and actually i
chaired that group specifically to try
and understand precisely
where the risks were uh predominantly in
residents going into care homes and
because of the very high infection rates
and there were two pieces of work
commissioned around that
and although the data is quite complex
to interpret
it was very clear at the end of this
work
that the there are different ways for
the virus to come into care homes
and it can come from a hospital
discharge but that is definitely not
the majority route of entry it's coming
as community cases rise
and care workers are going in and out as
they do because we need them to provide
care it's coming in with community rates
and we see that with schools as well
so i think it's just about really
looking at the evidence of where
transmission occurs which is important
thanks very much laura next question is
from carl dineen from itv
hi secretary of state uh you've
explained
why you didn't test everyone going from
hospital to care home but
the charge from dominic cummings is
actually quite specific and i'd like to
try again on that
did you tell the prime minister that
everyone going from hospital to care
home
would be tested or is dominic cummings
not telling the truth on that
of course we committed and i committed
to getting the policy in place
but it took time to build the testing
you know we didn't start with a big
testing
system in the uk and then we built that
testing system
and that's why the hundred thousand
target was so important because it
really accelerated the
the availability of testing because when
you don't
have much testing we we had to click
we had to prioritize it according to
clinical need
and so that was the approach that we
took in fact we set all of this out at
the time
but you know it is important in terms of
looking back on it
that what we had to do was build the
testing capacity
because there simply wasn't at the start
of the pandemic
that testing capacity in place we had to
put it in place
and that's the action that i took thanks
very much the next question is from beth
rigby at sky
thank you secretary of state just to
follow up on that and specifically mr
cummings said yesterday
that you categorically said in the
cabinet room in march
that people were going to be tested
before
going back into care homes mr collins
went on to say that he and the prime
minister
subsequently found out that hadn't
happened
he said far from putting a shield around
people they were sent
back to care homes untested so just to
be clear
did you make the statement in march that
they would be tested
before going back to care homes and that
didn't turn out to be true because you
didn't have the testing system
in place is that what really happened no
i
look there will be a time when we go
back over all this in great detail
but my recollection of events
is that i committed to delivering
that testing for people going from
hospital into care homes
when we could do it i then went away and
built the testing capacity for all sorts
of reasons and all sorts of uses
including this one and then delivered on
the commitment that i made
and that is a that's kind of normal way
of how you get things done in government
you work out what needs to happen
you commit to making it happen you go
away and deliver on that commitment
and then you can put the policy in place
and um
you know there'll be a time when we can
go through all this
in greater detail the most important
thing right now
is that we've still got a pandemic to
handle and to manage
and hence the announcements that we're
making today on vaccination
and the work that we're doing to try to
make sure we keep this epidemic under
control